you can also join the discussion on the
david pakman show
subreddit which you can find at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
nearly 30 000 of our viewers and
listeners are now subscribed
free to the david pakman show subreddit
some interesting posts
i like this one someone posted to
david's will never see on fox news again
me after my last fox news appearance
and david leopold the immigration
attorney who we covered earlier this
week
who called out fox host judge janine
pirro
over the weekend i think that is fair to
say
i don't think i will ever be back on fox
news actually you know
i don't know that i don't think i'll be
back on the weekend news hours
the fox fox really you know each show is
its own thing i think it's plausible
that i'd be back on some other show but
i don't think they'll have me back on
the weekend america's news headquarters
after my last appearance and yes i don't
think david leopold is going to be back
on fox news anytime soon
user portland hipster suggests
that i start referring to donald trump
as a former one-term
president trump and that it will trigger
quote
right-wing cucks yeah i think that the
syntax
former one-term president trump um
the i think that it makes more sense to
say the one-term
former president donald trump or just
the one-term
president donald trump um yeah i like
that idea i think that that's definitely
an adjustment that uh
i i would easily be able to make on the
show when referring to donald trump
and then user a what the cheese
posted about anti-vaxx math pointing out
that
the u.s has seen 30 million dollars i'm
sorry 30 million
30 million confirmed coronavirus cases
the real number could be anywhere up to
you know two to three times higher than
that 550 000 coveted deaths
125 million vaccine doses administered
now it's closer to 130.
1900 vaccinated people that died
and no one that we know of who has died
from the vaccine
and yet anti-vaxxers somehow seem to
think
that the vaccine might be more dangerous
to them than coronavirus yeah of course
the math doesn't work and what you have
to also remember
even about so there's a lot here that's
even understated right we have no
deaths linked to the vaccine that's true
but even deaths of people who died after
being vaccinated
uh when you vaccinate tens of millions
of people
by sheer math some of the vaccinated
people will die
from an actuarial perspective of old age
of other conditions etc so um
i think that it's very important to put
this math in perspective it's also
important to remember you know on
anti-vax math
what else are anti-vaxxers scrutinizing
to the degree that they claim to be
scrutinizing vaccines and ingredients
and this type of thing
i mean do they ever eat junk food do
they understand
what all of the elements are in junk
food on the ingredient list
when they buy shampoo when they buy skin
creams and toothpaste and whatever
are are they scrutinizing the um
uh uh i don't know if they're called
ingredients when it comes to health and
beauty products but
are they scrutinizing everything that is
in those products to this degree
there's definitely a uh it's sort of
like
sometimes people become there's this
thing orthorexia
where people become fixated on diet to a
degree that that's unhealthy it's almost
like a diagnosable
condition and you start to wonder you
know
what else do you obsess about to this
degree in your life
outside of your diet and maybe we should
apply some context i think the same
thing applies to many anti-vaxxers where
great you're really concerned about um
what what's in the vaccines that's fine
are you equally concerned when you get
antibiotics are you equally equally
concerned when you buy tylenol are you
equally concerned when you look at junk
food
have have you ever looked at the
ingredients in zebra cakes
uh and i'm kind of half kidding maybe
zebra cakes don't have anything that
crazy in them i used to love those as a
kid i really did
zebra cakes anyway join the discussion
um on the david pakman show subreddit
davidpakman.com
reddit one of our sponsors is vincero
watches giving you 15 off a high quality
wristwatch
is the perfect way to elevate your style
own at least one
watch that makes you feel great when you
put it on you can often see me wearing
my vincero watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman